la qualité de ce samedi en france avec
d'abord la marche des fiertés la
traditionnelle gay pride qui cette année
après un temps d'avancé sur 2007 la
campagne présidentielle est déjà ouverte
sur un thème de société qui pourrait
faire la différence
le mariage et l'adoption pour les
couples du même sexe
en tête de cortège françois hollande et
de nombreuses personnalités du ps
anne-sophie cheminots quand jean-marc
note un défilé haut en couleur politique
au coude à coude avec les habitués de la
gay pride
françois hollande tente de se faire une
place en 1996 il était venu défendre le
pacs je viens d'y gens apprennent à la
veille d'une échéance importante pour
dire que sur la question du mariage de
l'ouvrir au cou quelle que soit leur
orientation sexuelle
l'égalité pour tous si la gauche a
tranché est sorti c'est tête d'affiche à
l'ump on préfère envoyer les jeunes en
éclaireur pour la première fois le parti
a même financé un char
du mpda partie de liberté certains
s'expriment contre ils ont le droit de
le faire contre le mariage gay d'autres
textes et une pour nous comme la ayant
tous qu'ils ont fini loin des discours
politiques
valérie et wanda sont là pour témoigner
elles sont maman de deux enfants et
milite pour être enfin comme elles
disent des citoyennes à part entière
on ne s'avance et marié ça fait 20 ans
qu'on vit ensemble donc
donc voilà on espère que les politiques
- qui peut se réveiller parce que
la société elle nous accepte plutôt bien
mais les politiques sont très en retard
six cent mille personnes dans la rue
deux fois plus que l'an dernier
le débat sur le mariage gay et
l'homoparentalité sera difficile à
occulter d'ici l'élection présidentielle